- hey poppy here it's Papa John and
you're listening to the h3 podcast go
Ethan go Ayla go Ayla go even well it's
a dark day on the horizon but we have
Papa John here to assure us to make us
feel safe and we also have here with us
the glamorous Trisha Paytas with the
thousand dollar Gucci well I did say you
were three XL back today you forgot
about that's fine I'll take it we're
making progress and you guys also
thought I had Corona your producer is
Zack we're like I don't know if you
should come today and you guys were all
already here so it was clearly just me
well no Ethan wasn't here yet first of
all we were debating if we should cancel
because it's so crazy well yeah there's
been a lot of madness with Corona I'm
I'm like I said I'm more afraid of
giving it to you and then killing your
grandma but you said your grandma's
already dead because the truth is it's
really just old people who are gonna
people are calling it the boomer remover
Oh like fed up by our government to kill
old people no I think it's just a memes
because all the boomers are gonna perish
they will eventually I mean we all will
mmm that's how I feel it's true oh by
the way today's episode is sponsored by
hims not associated with the pandemic
also I wanted to say that PewDiePie is
scheduled to join us on what is today on
Tuesday of next week that's right via
Skype yeah he was he was meant to be
here today but obviously he couldn't
make it because of the he had some yeah
the virus you know so he had to
reschedule until Tuesday you're a lying
dog so what if I would jail bite and say
that about me
so the show must go on as we were saying
we were thinking of canceling but we had
very much been looking forward to round
two of The Bachelorette starring Trisha
Paytas he's so excited and that's why
when I was gonna get canceled I was
gonna cancel you guys I got to cancel
today I would have just never showed up
ever again really yeah personal it
wasn't we really was no
are freaking out so I wasn't sure if
it's not okay of us to even ask you to
come right now because people are
quarantined yeah I think everything just
personal and I don't think about anyway
that's well that's good I'm glad we
clear you up because I said you know
what
yeah these guys were nervous about it
and I said let's call Tricia and see how
she feels because I was I was actually
considering you're voting to do the show
yeah I was voting to not doing not
because of you that's how it is well
there you go I'm gonna I'm glad that we
cleared that let's just call and see how
she feels about it can I keep this mug
absolutely I love my yellow and I post
every day that's our payment to you for
participating in ourselves but the show
must go on I know the news everywhere is
covered with the happenings of the wiki
day the wicked hoax of the coronavirus
not a hoax but we are here to entertain
the people must be entertained many
people are quarantined schools schools
are being closed all around the country
all school counties closed I thought it
was only [ __ ] old people no but you
did because that's how it spreads you
don't want people to get it I mean
there's it's not only old people it
could be someone with any other
pre-existing conditions like could be
young and have I don't problems and then
one of our employees that Teddy
fresh-fruit vample has like type 1
diabetes and he's very at risk so we're
very concerned but was so we sat we sent
all of our Teddy fresh employees home
today we are making sure just basically
I just want to make sure that these
three guys in back get infected but
everyone at Eddie fresh we want to stay
healthy has anyone actually died from
Corona yeah dude like tens of thousands
shut up I always I heard it was like a
300 or something someone said well
globally but the in China a lot of
people died because there was a lot more
cases right now there's about a hundred
thousand confirmed case or like 110
thousand worldwide but now in the United
States and in Europe it's it's and in
the Middle East worldwide it's gone it's
that expedite
she'll gross I just looked it up it's
just a little over 5,000 deaths
worldwide so that's gonna be once
basically once we run out of hospital
beds and then let's not talk about it
you've got this everywhere aids we're
here too we're here to date and I see so
I see you you've dressed for the
occasion tell me about what you're
wearing
yeah I just want to just like look a
little classier last time I was on the
show I looked a little bit like a cheap
hooker the Lighting's in you're really
bad and I also was really fat and I was
like you know what let me just not eat
so I stopped eating for a week after
last episode and you guys look better in
person too I was so weird I first met
you guys was like they're so
good-looking but on camera you guys look
crazy and I think it's the lighting you
just look older like I literally thought
you were 42 but in person you look 27
and st. you like so that's I was 27 yeah
thank you so much I think it's the
lighting that's not doing anyone justice
or something make you look better look
great this podcast yeah I'm looking at
myself I look like I'm people think I'm
like a different ethnicity which I'm
totally fine with people thinking that
but I'm like that's how I look I look
like Dan what do you answer that
that's an electrician the girl from
Martin that tisha campbell-martin
I mean that's fine but like that is not
who I look like in real life and she's
pretty and I will take it as a
compliment but and what are your
fingernails today last time you had
dollar bills in there it's still dollars
I'm gonna get them off next week okay
they match your dress and your dress if
you I don't I mean I don't want to be
rude I mostly come off this way but it
does remind me of a curtain it's
inspired it's like a country singer like
Dolly Parton from the 60s meets like
Sharon Tate but that's what's cold I
don't want to like a hoochie has look
let me be conservative for my nip was
actually out the whole episode we're
like no you could see a little aerial
areola but the nip was peeking out just
a little bit it was it was snoring I can
show you I can know
you know I don't I mean okay oh it's
scarring so they're your nipples now
thank you very much
what was that Vin Diesel Oh Vin Diesel's
a fan I love is he gonna be on today cuz
I will die to see one of the contestants
well let's find out by the way so today
we continue the Bachelorette round two
we have for you Tricia we have 2324
video applicants for you to choose
through today and you should be happy to
know we had well over 200 applications
is that right then yeah yeah even maybe
even a little bit more than people were
banging at the door they wanted a piece
of Trisha Paytas so you should be very
flattered you're in high demand
I am actually I'm really surprised like
the same as like I wouldn't surprise
like anyone even did a video well we've
got a lot and I'm excited because I
haven't seen these these guys went
through it they made a shortlist first
all to review I haven't even seen these
so I'm these are good I haven't been
insured these are really good and are
they ever gonna come in in person or no
yes of course absolutely eventually they
come in so the next round we are going
to choose the ones that you like I'm
hoping that's around 10 but I'm not
gonna be so strict the ones you don't
like we're gonna eliminate viciously
with prejudice
what's with prejudice mean just save
just make them feel like regret even
submitting a video but yeah well not
today of course not today
you he'll be oh thank you you look great
oh my god I know you have for I can
notice right away how much I don't know
I haven't been I have no way I don't
like checking what I'm on a diet but you
are the first person to notice
besides ILA's mom you know I you know I
really noticed you because you're
wearing horizontal stripes which
normally would make someone look white
or NAS like weight you look thin and now
it but you're wearing stripes so you
should look heavier
so that's I know you're real skinny
because like no real know you I can tell
by your face your body that's wise like
today you look 27 yeah when people start
losing weight see with me what am i fat
miserable [ __ ] I'm miserable but when I
lose well it's true it's so true
like the big motivating factor for me to
lose weight
besides being wanting to be more
attractive for take Eden want to touch
me now is that I'm just kidding it's not
that bad but I know she does want to
touch me is that no yeah come on you're
more attractive to me skinny I mean I
want him to lose weight yes I think my
body grotesque do you because when I see
myself naked I look like I go ILA's look
in the mirror the other day and I'm
naked and I'm looking at my bad
positions that make him look worse and I
think now - it doesn't make you look
great like if you said my stomach
resting but when you stand you look very
alike thin and nice and like a mask and
here you just like to look like I don't
be on purpose
whatever it is I'm comfortable but I'm
looking at my backside of the mirror
like not only just my ass and thighs but
my back everything sagging you know I
look like the top of a cottage cheese
container
my whole body dude mine - my belly I eat
a lot of cottage cheese got the 8% [ __ ]
that should know I try it like there's
like a zero percent like anything that
one's that one's a abomination so in
Israel we have a 9% cottage cheese and
it's really like the same thing like no
dude it's like cream cheese there's so
much fat in it and I used to hate
cottage cheese until I went to Israel
and saw what the real deal is so we
found some boutique cottage cheese at
Whole Foods so I look at the most fat I
can't find it's it's still not that fat
yeah it's cute we should be the final
episode in Israel how about Motel 6
I mean down for that dude I'll make
whatever let's just guy I'm just
thinking what's in the budget
every every Jewish China huh
how about a cruise to China would you go
on a cruise with the winner they kill me
don't you
no but I mean it would be interesting to
vlog a cruise for two that's what we
were thinking the winter being anywhere
you want oh really
you can go find a tenant twenty day
cruise wait we get a prize after all
this absolutely we gotta send the two
winners on our vacation we actually yeah
a 20-day cruise I'm serious I'm on for
sincerity go to what does that place
called with the Penguins up north what
is that oh that's in the South honey
Antarctica's south well I guess
direction is relative but I think
considered north if you're in Antarctica
the continent above us well there's
there isn't one Antarctica are you alive
Arthur do you want me to show you a
glove would you like to see a globe over
there please actually I kind of know I'm
right on hundred you know the globe is
not helping let's look at a world map
I've been Antarctica well you're just to
see pictures of Antarctica so here is
the globe as we know it and if you can
spot an article it's not that much work
so where is Antarctica here we are
here's the United States right okay but
see it's it's round yes it is round
right right it depends on how the globe
is spinning I don't think so
I think direction well I think the
purpose of the compass is so that it's
always relative no matter where your
position does on earth not rotate it
does but but but you rotate in in
relativity to Antarctica so at one point
once our access rotating then the
antyram has on the top because we rotate
where the ball gave me a bottom roll so
then I've got a basketball so you're
saying if if the world is upside down
but you know the world spins on its axis
that's right okay okay
you're I think you're right I think
you're right Antarctica is in the north
you want to go to Antarctica I do I love
the Penguins okay we'll send you over
the Penguins ice where are you well I
don't think you can even go to
Antarctica without like a scientific
expedition passes I looked at it with oh
there's a cruise
okay let's send you news for sure just
you have to vlog it awesome guys
exclusive thank you for making me like
relevant again this is very exciting I
love you you're so far we've come
I know it is true you know I just had a
fast day with a youtuber and I'm like
you know what maybe in a year from now
we'll be fun Anthony buddy I do like
this whole hate video on it well not
hate video he hated me and I went back
anyway what yeah why is it me so lucky
and careful yes
What did he say about you talking about
like how I think I have like multiple
personalities and he's like no you don't
[ __ ] you for claiming this like and I
was like he's got it he's the type of
dude who gets offended for other people
yeah and also I was like I'm just
telling you how I feel like I do feel
like I have like wealth and everyone
comes at me yelling
so as other is other personalities
different genders yes oh so that
explains the the the gender dysmorphia
some personalities are trans some are
straight that's true oh that clears
everything up that makes it all so clear
I don't know why people don't believe
this people love to tell me I have all
personalities and I say and they're like
well there you have it anyways but
Anthony he said something annoying to me
once where I was talking about Oh on
your video the one that I said
Instagram reality he made some really
annoying comment about like do you
really think it's appropriate oh yeah he
goes do you really think it's
appropriate to talk about body shaming
when you're claiming that someone looks
like a beached whale
I was like yes bro
it's funny because it's like you know
what like you
that's so funny cuz he was kind of in a
way like sighting on me with that one
and then now for me he just wants to
come for everybody that like popular
he's just the good guy he's like the
good guy at all cost
which is like a sociopath like if you
believe that then you're the actual like
narcissus Anthony is a narcissistic
sociopath we've heard here folks I said
it I call him on my Instagram I went off
today I was like oh I want to pull it up
what the drama
whatever just ship it will get there
Trisha Paytas Instagram I want the beef
we're here for the beach no I look crazy
I was I was I was seeing red this
morning I was like so wait I see a post
of you oh and your outfit today yeah I
was getting for you guys and though it
looks good you look good in that photo
Thanks you should I'd like to do it ugly
like I'd like to do my serious ones ugly
so people know I'm being sincere but wow
that's good lighting good lighting I
would look like that here yeah we're not
gonna do that no I'll bring the camera
and I will smooth your face on the
camera yeah if I get a face can you do
our lighting here let me read the come
on let's talk about Anthony if in
defending myself makes me a crazy [ __ ]
then so be it I'm so sick and tired of
people discounting me as a [ __ ] human
being it's clear to anyone who has watch
me I've suffered from mental illness my
entire life well that's true that's yeah
we can all agree that there's a reason I
can't hold friendship relationships Sara
I'll be damned if I'm gonna let anyone
who doesn't know me tell me how my brain
functions and how my body feels would
you say that me and you are one of the
longest lasting relationships you've had
thousand percent yeah and you could ask
anyone I've had a relationship with like
even Jason like I have a switch where my
personality is somewhat differing he's
like I don't even recognize you when you
I think it's a different but I know it
happens I mean it's good to get really
close to me to see it so that's why I
was like [ __ ] Anthony Padilla for
doing this but yeah so we have a we have
a perp we have a good distance maybe I
only see you like once a month I don't
like this either I get really mad I
watch your eyes podcast Muhammad house
there oh no you don't though cuz you'd
hate me too so then what did it where do
i how do I see what I see sorry
well was it
where I went off like look at all my
little tabs oh how can I wash dishes
story from my laptop
how what did he say where do I see it
it was just on his Instagram story I
think what it's [ __ ] Anthony Padilla
have to be logged in watch drama
let's see someone's gonna have this the
results oh you can always like two
minutes long here everybody wants to
know happen on your Instagram story
because you say I'm claiming to have a
mental disorder and then I'm mocking the
people with a similar mental disorder as
me well [ __ ] you you dumb piece of [ __ ]
I am ashamed embarrassed and scared you
are a mental health advocate and that
people are coming on to your show to
share their stories to have an open and
safe discussion when you just accuse me
of claiming that I have in this article
depression anxiety are you sure [ __ ] me
you're know what goes on inside my head
you're never in a relationship with me
you're not related me can you imagine
being in a relationship with someone
else and you're switching your different
person like who was it that was a
different person [ __ ] scary that is
you dumb piece of [ __ ] call me [ __ ]
trash or carry my [ __ ] mental health
struggles and not anyone else's not any
of your stupid shitty people at you
exploit o your void if you're a shitty
person and I am so [ __ ] scared for
anyone to go on your show so you can
make money and you can be like this
white knight and all this [ __ ] like that
and then you just turn around while you
go up I was I was like such an advocate
I loved his show and I always said that
to everyone I mean I'm obsessed with
Anthony but yeah like that wasn't so
crazy as I loved him and then for him to
like you and I was like oh he's doing
this stuff like awareness and he is a
little self-indulgent
to be on I mean you can't reverse but
everyone kind it is aren't they I guess
maybe you guys are like humble though
because you guys are like you know your
people yeah I just roll my eyes super
anyway it's like confidence you know I
would love to see what he said to you I
gotta open it I'm sorry I'm not over
this let's go to party
I mean I get you're angry maybe then
maybe you can come and login here on
look at everyone doing these videos
about me like did he was a girl he just
it on his story so that's what I got to
find now I got to look for part two but
it saw him talking it's like it's akin
typing it wasn't like his face I'm
[ __ ] he started beef and then he
[ __ ] [ __ ] now hmm and then he's like
girlfriend did one of them watching my
video and rolling their eyes I was like
[ __ ] dance got it good trying to get
some [ __ ] views myself but it's true
that's what you said I don't know the
[ __ ] his name babe he's scared of me
he'll never call me because I come like
that's a thing people are talking about
me I'm talking about my own mental
health and then people are coming for me
and I'm like don't talk about me like
I'm not talking about anyone else I'm
not coming for anyone like I hate that
Anthony Padilla I mean even this photos
a little like the confidence so he said
oh yeah claiming you have disassociative
identity disorder is not a cool excuse
to mock people in the community and call
them crazy
did you mocked anyone exactly I wasn't
even in a video I'm like I'm not just
respecting anyone anything
and then like did you see the next slide
he did look oh how do I do that right
there you can watch my video to learn
like he's promote his own video right
after I like watch mine that I did about
this know what before actually haven't
they're talking about it I think he's
just a little too sensitive he's just a
little too much of a good guy he means
to [ __ ] [ __ ] up because seriously
you're on the [ __ ] Internet you dumb
prick just cuz your channel is dying and
now you have to like exploit other
people's stories to resurrect it would
you get
the ring with him like logan paul vks i
like boxing thank you [ __ ] him up above
you're sure I do that bolus air and [ __ ]
yeah I would literally like yeah that
would be awful alright oh why do guys
come for me it's never a girl like you
like girls never come from it's always
like these men and I'm like [ __ ] you you
little like [ __ ] [ __ ] like I hate that
[ __ ] like you can't comfort like someone
like your own level like he's not gonna
come for a chain toss and you know what
I mean like oh he wouldn't ever happen
they come for me cuz I'm an easy target
and I like no matter what like even like
the nikah kado think everyone was like
on my ass be like [ __ ] you and then once
another girl did it they're like oh my
god Nick you're so evil like here I'm
not following the ghosting thing right I
owe ya like everyone hated me forever
and I got cancelled for it
literally six months later another girl
named Stephanie see it was a huge drama
she said that like she goes to Nick and
then she was scared of him which is what
I said prior and I was like oh my god
Nick you're such a monster why would you
force someone to hang out with you like
the exact same situation happened six
months later but because it's like it's
like a [ __ ] girl in school if she gets
raped it's like oh she's a [ __ ] but I'd
like the good girl in school gets raped
it's like oh my god like did you could
you believe what happened to her like I
hate that [ __ ] I hate it and that's me
forever because I'm like crazy
well standard people I see what you're
saying yes always gonna be the crazy one
and I'll never they won't in short
before we move on because if we should
get to the we should get to the dating
but I will say that their shots fired at
Anthony Padilla and he should show his
face and not be a coward yes I called
him his girlfriend a coward I mean
you're gonna admin to me you're gonna
roll you don't at me at least you came
you came for me you know you kept like
putting my name in the title oh yeah
let's go and now look at us I know how
are you watching before the 90 days
that's big because I love be good well
he's he's a he's a star his stars rising
as they say I heard you said that his PR
person was like very strict about him
his handler was crazy I love that
episode I love I love they get i90
fiance is not realized so I want to ask
you before we're gonna hit a break in
eight minutes and then we'll do the
dating but ice know that you quit
YouTube recently since then you made
nine videos are you quitting YouTube I
counted
I'm not making YouTube a priority is
what I never titled my video I'm
quitting YouTube everyone picked up on
that I just had it's no longer a
priority like it's not something I'm
gonna like really focus on but ever
since I did that now I can't stop making
videos cuz I have a lot to say but it's
not a priority
I make no money on it no I'm on only
fans only do you you announce that do
you think the coronavirus will be good
for your only fans career because think
about all these guys everyone's at home
you can't you can't go meet people
everyone's at home just jerking off yeah
dishes at her house squirting all over
her bed yeah I might be like a little
piece but I feel like people love it
like you do yeah they love that how many
how many fans followers do you have
subscribers Oh 12,000 Wow 12,000 and me
and what do they pay you per month
what's the membership in it like didn't
we see just recently was like twelve
bucks a month or something oh you said
it
it's like twelve originally it's twenty
dollars but I do like discounts like
I'll do like promotions for seven days
you can get it for like so what is so
but it's 20 usually mm-hmm but we don't
make money with oh let me do the quick
math that's 120 km um no but no but then
you you send a video and private
messages it's even more for the tip so
you're making more than a hundred money
did they take from you yeah you are Wow
really but flat there it'll happen yeah
I guess the same as like streamers on
Twitch so that sounds about right yeah I
mean it's everything I did my first girl
girl on there I saw that in your
announcement video how excited so you
did your first girl girl how was that
girls but obviously not on camera so I
was like holla nervous I never really
did like a porn thing I was like it's
masturbation it's fine I never did
something with someone else so I have
one more grogger and then I'm done I'm
address court on each other that's to
come house AK says you did it with Alina
the plug I'm aware of her yeah
we're friends so but I have one next
week what's like a three-way with me her
in another like pornstar
blood female yeah how do three females
have sex do you scissor [ __ ] each other
yeah you can roll just like you just
think about it like a regular thing like
a regular scissor circle who's gonna be
the third one I can say yeah but it'll
yeah well that's very exciting by the
way congratulations to you I mean I yeah
I mean dude listen before the show
started you said you started your career
doing $5 [ __ ] and now look at you
making probably $200,000 a month on only
fans I mean that is amazed that is a
true success story your natural-born
hustler and I and you know goddamn it
I respect the hustle I know you guys
were watching sponge videos I was like
sponge video I was okay you gained
publicity to my competition honeybee
ASMR you're like uma hurt sponges look
good it's true but it's true you're
sponges did not look anywhere close as
good as her sponges were so she has like
the Gucci level spine Brandis [ __ ] know
what what is going on with no talkie
Trisha ASMR what is happening I don't
know what's the inspiration as you
what's your favorite one here oh my God
look at that thumbnail is that your time
now that you broke no I make no money
but I love it it's so much fun can you
tell me what's inspiration for crunching
a head of lettuce I know I know it's I
was so proud of myself close up so now I
do makeup and [ __ ] I was kinda like
whatever okay you always highlight me
looking the grossest wait why are you
eating a candle who's that for probably
how many number one youtuber
ever right now david dobrik he gets more
views than david why what does he do he
just eats and doesn't talk no really
that maybe he does he gets like 250
million we had a falling out I was so in
love with him but we have a low volume
you guys ate candles together and then
you fell out yeah what does that
traitors have paid us cuz we don't like
type wait how did he how did he um how
did you guys fall out yeah the nikah
kado thing and then I was like on drugs
so I was like the ring woman I ever saw
each other on the bottle he posed on
drugs anymore I was and when there's the
poly I happened like December a lot of
you post quite frequently - Arnie type
exact Reuters penis could be had a
really good one I'm really proud of this
alright I promise you you won't be
disappointed of this ASMR this is like
so good we've done a bunch oh yeah there
oh god these are so good they like turns
because a freak look at that wait 18
million 12 million I gotta watch this
one dude you guys are this guy's a freak
bro so thin I know what the hell is that
what's wrong with it was so much cheese
what does he do this guy just something
[ __ ] up this guy's twisted right be on
it people always have a small stomachs
and small bodies you know oh my god it's
cheese it likes cheese and potato he's
so smart and I like no no no tell me
really this guy's [ __ ] up oh no this
guy's twists you kind of looks like a
cheetah serial killer rape that guy it
does like he probably takes laxatives or
something oh yeah I'm sure are people
attracted to him that why he's so
popular like that girl you said she was
thin and pretty in comparison to me I
write after me like this girl's been an
attractive and eating sponges I was like
okay so the primary audiences be no it
wasn't even about that joy I mean I
would take it personally exactly I was
so not I have issues can we talk about
this house can we talk about is actually
he
and talk he won't talk Allah he won't do
podcast he won't talk what is wrong I
don't know and so is the people who
watch this females who want to be eating
and are attracted to him
I think females is anyone masturbating
to this me swear god I was so in love
with or no no I was I used to where I
was he came to my Christmas party we did
like collabs does he know that you would
masturbate to him I think so he straight
actual yeah does he [ __ ] with food I
don't think he does know what I met him
he had a girlfriend then he blew up and
got really rich and like the girlfriends
gone now and he just like dates a bunch
of hos oh my god this guy he's got
skeletons in the closet yeah for sure my
dream has come true this was the
happiest day of my life he's
deliberately putting the most talk of
people in the videos making him sit
there let's get him off the screen all
right well well so it's break time we
will go to a quick break and when we
come back it is finally time to start
the Bachelorette
[Applause]
we are back we have alleviated our
bladders Gila has emptied her : no I'm
just kidding I just thought it'd be
funny the image of ela taking a pill
don't exactly there was weird tension
between you two when I walked in today
and I feel like you guys should talk
about that more on the podcast cuz you
guys seem perfect on the podcast and I
wanna apologize to hila and I was like
oh there's mention here yeah you want to
tell them what I did well okay yeah now
I don't remember so we didn't say
anything on the podcast no yeah I don't
remember um that shirt is really cute
well I'm not just saying bad timing when
I'm about to say why I was upset at you
go ahead well we had discussed last
night that we would tell our employees
to work from home next week starting
Monday so today
try me trying to get more work done
because I know we have the podcast I was
like okay I'll go early before the
podcast to get some stuff done before
cuz Ethan he's always late to the
podcast and then it takes forever so we
I come in and I walk into the office and
I know I was supposed to meet some
people and they're like oh you're here
Ethan said we're all evacuating and we
packed our stuff and I was like well it
didn't tell me his wife who lives with
him did not tell me that we're kind of
lying so I was upset yes and rightfully
so
now tokes now let me explain my side so
I don't look like a total psycho right
well so a lot had come out in that
morning when I was watching the news
that they canceled all the schools in LA
and our managers were kind of like
yesterday there they were of the opinion
when we were all talking with our
managers were like oh it's not that big
of a deal one of our got one of our
dudes who's Cuban he goes trust me I
grew up in Cuba and I've seen it so bad
that people used to melt condoms on meat
like it was cheese and eat it well as I
will Wow
he said that to me what why
but regardless so but then this morning
when I when it's like everything's
closing the schools are closing and and
then also I found out the two employees
you didn't know this but we had two
employees who called in sick well Keesha
you knew about but ADA called in sick I
shouldn't say their names let who cares
whatever and I was like [ __ ] that to
people calling in sick with symptoms I
said okay everybody out
but I was talking in our manager chat
and so I thought I just assumed even
either was driving to work I assume she
saw it obviously you were driving you
eye but it's only a 20-minute drive so
thought maybe you were there I wasn't
thinking I definitely [ __ ] up though I
should have called and consulted you
first saw me first yeah before I liked
that collateral and really yeah
absolutely
no ideas but I'm with you 100% called
and consulted you first so yeah this is
real I yeah I mean I don't talk about
that he was like groveling towards you
and I was like well he should do that on
the podcast like say I'm so sorry you're
a team
you might Jesus his mother too I just
realized that you can play Marian like
the scene you're so pretty
anyways was married pretty Mary was
gorge was it I'm your expect me to
believe she was virgin Mark Burnett wife
played her in the Jesus movie I forget
her name she's famous she's beautiful
but I did I did I did mess up and I knew
when I came in that I that I was wrong I
got a buyer like a ring with a diamond
or something no well it's her with her
money why would she want me to spend
more money wait you're you're richer
than him no we share we have any money
you know what I mean like what am I
gonna go buy her an expensive yeah
obviously married for 10 years
we're actually forced to share bank
account from our first moment like
dating technically Wow yeah not legal
yeah I don't know no sign of Taurus not
even the cameras oh but you're like okay
let's get married so you stay here no no
that was enough
I got married in Israel happens I'll
feel like in love with someone you're
like oh that makes sense we should get
married it like stay here yeah but
that's not what happened I just came
here to live with him for like six
months until I had to leave the tourists
yeah but while we were here we basically
hadn't like we didn't have like the
normal dating stage we just went
straight into living together sharing
bank account you couldn't open a big
thing oh I guess yeah I was like just
give me your money
oh but you had money I just brought
everything I had which wasn't a lot [ __ ]
that was everything that I had oh I
think you had like 1500 bucks and I had
like 1500 bucks without we're balling
hard was through nothing but then we all
want and then we were paying rent and
rant and rant and then we're like I was
like oh you have to go you're gonna have
to leave we can't pay rent married no no
I went I moved to Israel I lived there
for five years and we got married there
we were set but anyway this is about you
Trish you guys are very 90-day fiance
and I'm like why are there no Israeli
people on that if it wasn't really
90-day fiance because I moved to Israel
for five years we were very established
and comfortable there I had a good job
Eva was in school crushing it and then
and then once you finish school and
after we got married after living there
for five years we applied for a green
card to bring her over okay and we
waited yes that's so cool
because it's really men always trying
like you know get me to marry them that
happened like a long time ago when I
lived at the Grand Sherman Oaks there's
a ton of Israeli guy right that's what
I'm saying so I don't want that kind of
noise really guys no you're not gonna
let's let's here we got a Jewish not a
Jewish not that's what we'd like to be
called okay so here we go the winners
this is what I'm thinking the winners
that we'd select here today well in the
next round
call in via Skype for a one-on-one speed
date with three minutes to seduce you
seduce
yeah all right man you know to woo you
too
to make you like them and so from them
we will continue to narrow it down the
winner will be going on a cruise to
Antarctica dan look up crews say Hardin
is that a real thing huh you know what
she wasn't lying there how much is it
how much is it well right now all
cruises are like nothing um I just buy
the tickets already now's a good time to
shop no but how much is it look ten
night cruise to enter tell me how much
this one is nine grand per person or for
both per person I'm not paying up
$20,000 what am I I don't sponsor it's a
16 night cruise to Antarctica leaving
from San Antonio Texas and it's 2700
dollars per person that's what's up I'm
saying you guys to Texas I was just in
San Antonio it's disgusting well you
know I would never fly into that Airport
okay no I need why is that one so much
cheaper the prices are fluctuating yeah
what is $20,000 one because it's a
first-class I am NOT going in a place
with no window I am NOT going on a
cruise oh you're gonna be in a little no
I'm not I need to wait we need some kind
of sponsor to pay for Ash 10 fresh is
not sponsoring the show yeah they always
do you're always expensive exactly
someone else's money to pay for it well
we're only Teddy fresh on the cruise
I'll do my own will you squirt and the
color-block hoodie not publicly traded
at unfortunately yeah it looks like it
it all fluctuates between like five
grand and about $20,000 is that
dude do you want to spend twenty forty
thousand dollars on that's 40s or 20k
for the good one do we know that that's
a good one or not because we're gonna
sit well settle online how about that
all right we better milk this for all
it's worth I do
swipe up I do everything well how they
gonna charge me nine thousand dollars
for a cruise during a HEPA delivering a
[ __ ] pandemic
maybe Corona can't survive in the cold
of Antarctica actually actually it's the
heat that kills it I think it flourishes
in the cold well frozen you freeze lice
I think lice is a little different like
I don't have lice not currently I'm
basically bald zone you are bald yeah I
have like not a lot of hair what is what
are you doing right now is just a wig
extension this is my real hair but like
it's very short it's really sure it's
like I'll brush orders you're broken and
brittle the bleach and I tease it a lot
mm-hmm I'll fake it's all fake yep
usually like normal like shampoo and
everything yeah it's just like just wait
her sweat her wig or or that is it's not
a way to 6 inches do you wash your
extensions yeah of course you know I'm
not nasty
I don't know basically like real hair
how frequently do you change or what do
you need to do about it well I think
about at night they're clips so you like
clip them in depending on your style so
I clipped in I like long lines that long
ones on yesterday you were with a guy
and he's like whoa no can think guys are
like used to it now and if they are then
I'm like oh you have it with a lot of
girls cuz I ever girl holiday is like
some sort of extensions and I've never
been with it I have never been with a
girl with extensions so I think it would
shock me I don't know it was less say
yeah it's been a while yeah I'm just
good were you with people before Allah
like girls yeah really yeah you think
I'm a virgin I before his love story as
like a leave Riley never had sex before
she was like so excited about this like
military girl
no I've had sex before EULA yes that was
out are you press wait like 19 - so it
wasn't like that far-fetched right
weren't you really young no it was 20
let's get to the like I was bad insecure
like that's true I'm so [ __ ]
okay well don't [ __ ] I wasn't always fat
you're skinny I used to I used to be a
your assumption is not far from the
truth I'm not bad I'm not offended I
mean but I did I have no other people
before me so mad but you are your actual
process right I mean were yeah so but
where's the logic with what being angry
at dudes who slept with people before oh
it's just being like a hypocrite
okay but you were who's your ideal man
virgin virgin not ideal yeah no I
probably but it's hard to find all right
let's go we'll find out in the next
round of diversion okay this comes from
Jason Grimes he sent the video with this
note he said thank you for the
opportunity I appreciate your visit
Jason Mase Mason grind so here we go
Mason's where do I look here Oh nine
minutes
what's your first take on his looks
go ahead yo turn it up a little bit it's
quiet not my like typical tight but hey
my name is Mason 30 years old
my birthday is November 14th 1989
officially I can be a Scorpio take it or
leave it
oh they're gonna leave it you're leaving
this man openly or this won't be a yeah
we're not you idiot you better be a
whole totally honest and Oprah you're
not going to n artists I don't
I mean though so I'm not gonna be mean
I'm just gonna say like it I am like
nobody's have everything's I'm
disgusting so I'm not saying like I'm a
hot prize this is just probably we're
not compatible for a number of reasons
yes Batman
Batman there's a lot of Batman I don't
do it I can't do comic and he's got like
some kind of oh but that's so nice and I
like should we watch more thank you but
let me see if he does like a mukbang or
something yeah he does oh he does what's
he eating pizza pepperoni and typically
it's where when I have more than four
digits in my bank account
Oh broke they'll love that interested
now Caesars do by the way yeah I can't
and the Batman really throws me off Oh
Mason
we appreciate the application but he
said take it or leave it
and we leave all right well don't worry
we got plenty more this one comes from
Nikko Sani he says hey guys sorry this
is late
well that's doesn't matter to me now
hope you still consider my best bread
whoa he's wait wait whoa whoa okay
sending it for a friend
he worked super hard on this entry what
is your what what why are you sending
this for your friend Fred no I think
what does he not know how to use the
internet I mean I find that so weird
okay Fred so what's on this table
because I got really ghetto looking
burger one slice of bread anything about
lighting not good they're like muscle
tanks I hate guys gonna thank Tom all
right well let's do it
wait but I have to say I'm getting red
flags from not back then why was
submitted by his friend I find that so
disturbing okay anyway here we go Chris
Fred submitted by Nico
I'm here on my kitchen floor and today
I'll be a sourdough baguette some
chicken sliders some burritos I got some
right here and some cheese dip whoa
that's what's up right where I know
oh wait wait what the [ __ ] was that hold
on all right let's just watch oh I make
some pretty mean cocktails yeah okay
okay I'm getting so turned on now I was
all about wow I love the way to eat yet
vegan neck done over canceled no but
there's so much fake food no it went
yeah well not good in he's going in with
his hand wait is he really a vegan cuz
he says it's cheese did I have a point I
think he's pulling the
multiple-personality you like a guy
who's fair I'm working out I do like the
guys fit no oh really oh he had ranch
ranch isn't vegan the fried thing was I
think a white did I get roll all the
same guy yes he's like charlie that's
cute we all got got we love that love he
did that it's very high level went over
my head no smarter than you look
yeah he's rolling and I like it so we
like his real name is Nico Nico or Fred
well we don't know
when I watched her mukbangs after first
interview on h3 I knew I was hooked
he found me through you guys put some
working yeah kind of hot too now I'm
like all got it
okay looks like we have our first
finalist all right so so let's wait and
see we have to go through what we have a
process we almost passed on him usually
I consider myself straight all right so
Fred again I'm just gonna race the
rejects I'm putting in notes - yeah Wow
okay we got a finalist we have someone
you could use him to have been smitten
by by Fred slash Nico I'm not gonna lie
some people have split into my teams and
showed me their video they sent to you
guys
oh that's how they just broke okay well
as long as you're up be honest if you
see one that you've already said you
have to know he wasn't one of them but
okay - so the next one we have is from
Miguel aka meet Mickey it's his nickname
but your kids but but horror kids sounds
Mexican I mean it looks Mexican but I'm
not saying it Miguel I mean you know any
Miguel's that aren't Mexico I have a
friend that has that same last name he's
from Salvador yeah American okay
no disp animals I'm down for that
I feel like they're like they said
they're good at sex is that not Hispanic
wait who oh my god well Dan correct us
we said he's Hispanic but he said no
that South America no you said South
America Salvador is in Central America
yes what continent is a part of North
that's North America but and then
where's that in relation to Antarctica
okay so Miguel and here's my video
submission I tried to make it as cringy
and awkward as I could at the same time
however to what you do what you need for
me but I don't mind getting roasted
please do roast me I hope you guys like
my video and I hope I make it to the
finalists I forgot to mention I'm from
Arizona I didn't know if that was
necessary PS I'm a big fan isn't that
funny how your fans like want you to
like rip them apart like you're known as
just being an [ __ ] no I please be
mean to me well so he I mean I don't
know if that's another time I mean why
is it so many views Dawg 500 views
that's good maybe if you are looking to
see if anyone's trying to date me okay
let's see what you got
Nikki's video submission I said it's
excited is her submission for the best
results
Peter smell a bright 20 watch oh and
this is my submission for the best heart
ab right here 20 wings with me first leg
traction right away that's I like oh my
Buffalo medium and five blazing let's
dig in right let's get it started here
we go
well you know what Tricia maybe you
don't really even like how I look right
now let me go change real quick I'll
take these with me I'm so horny right
now oh no I was working
oh what a legend let's take it wait way
to get it hey I'm impressed that these
people are good now let's do a game Wow
we're mucking with him here that's the
big deck right there oh you really are
horny right yeah
so turn on I was before but now I'm like
what the custom ideas look good I'm a
bit I'm a fan needs to be so I'll just
do some cuts in between do you thing
buddy because I think he's already a yes
but let's see wait hold on let's catch
this reference why or maybe three times
a week
I love me do you love wings I do you
like all this someone's recording
there's someone else there just how good
I am
I'm just saying
don't get too excited truth so what till
you get home like where are you okay
he's in no you can't communicate with
them that you ruined it today his tie
ends up in the ranch
yeah good 8:00 tomorrow all right I mean
Wow okay that's an only fans in ranch
cuz you're mad and just like a ranch
down the [ __ ] yeah huge I could hook up
with all these people after the show is
over you can but sure I mean well you're
supposed to marry the winner all your
fans I just want to be on your show
I feel like none of these guys actually
would be interested no I think they are
interested I think they are okay I went
through a lot of effort no they are
interested and anyway they have three
minutes you can they want to be with me
are you guys exactly yeah I mean you
could say the same about the real
bachelor show you know they just want to
be there to be famous I don't like
though I can tell okay but some couples
made it and they have kids right Ian
yeah yeah they're still in there in the
relationship
Ian is the one the main one with the
hair the one that you like made fun of
the other day oh the one that everyone's
angry that I yeah that's Ian the salary
to that guys one with the male yes main
guy is one that's why I didn't like yeah
yeah Ian is the one it's the one in the
corner and he's one I was on The
Bachelor yeah and he's in love oh I
thought it was a main guy yeah yeah I
asked are you and love I mean I think
yeah I am yeah he is yeah alright but
the season got ruined because they
started talking into the DMS and then
she refused to come on the show okay
that got him well yeah exactly that's
good that mean she liked him for him I
didn't want to be here so right no
actually she wanted to come on the ship
no no I have to correct the record she
was down to come on the show but Ian
didn't want her on the show that's what
happened you can ask her cuz she's
coming tonight
well she'll lie to me no I shouldn't say
that no she's coming to visit she
because he's not farmers coming to town
visit where though what in the
California okay but you're like she's no
we're not doing it
we're not there's no plan no we talked
about doing a company but the virus is
not nobody's coming to our house like am
I not invited to this party
no there's no there's no party she and
can you explain because there's no
there's no plan okay well he said she's
somebody's not you like what did you
mean by that
what did you hear for nine days so if
you come in contact with her you can she
she she should join us for an episode
let's see the next application that's on
a show you owe it to them thank you
thank you you guys can literally you
could maybe come to the wedding I would
I would expect to officiate it alright
let's move on we have so many
applications we already have two yeses
so let's go let's go ace Jack C white hi
my name is Jack C and I am your wildcard
I'm true I'm a fully transition trans
girl so when I heard that Trisha was
into t girls I figured I had to take my
chance
well I'm open about it I wish to be
fully recognized as a female you're not
fully you're either transitioned or not
but so if she's fully transitioned she
means that she has female genitalia okay
all right well Jack see which oh you're
not into that you want the penis but
isn't a t-girl shitty girl is someone
with the penis yes girls usually like
some either if they did it before this
is every they have the dick and if they
don't you girls are T girls no this is
that's wow this is why I love to you
girls cuz they go ultra feminine I have
to first give it up to tricks or Jack C
one minute that's what I'm talking into
girls typically but here's the thing
I couldn't even wait to eat this
corndog for the video I got this just
for this video is that really in France
oh yeah yeah it's not crazy they're like
so voice is like so natural well they
get voice like feminization surgery and
stuff like that I mean I've never I
don't think I've ever heard of a trans
person with the voice that sounded so
genuine you know yeah I love them do not
trying to be offensive on there's no
it's amazing that's why I love t girls I
don't date like regular like Jackson
okay here we go
eat it before I started filming so yeah
I would love to be the wild card I've
been watching ship ship for a long time
and I'm such a huge fan I am bisexual as
well actually I guess I'm pansexual so I
meaning everybody and everything I think
that she is like an amazing person deep
down even though maybe misjudged by a
lot of people I totally like I love
girls but I'm the one with the blue hair
so my name is Jack CY I will give you my
Instagram as well and oh yes actually so
it's hard to say a lot because he
realized he also wanted seeing me a
little but I would like he's so much she
gave me the chance even though I'm not a
guy even though I'm a girl he doesn't
have a dick which is a big right like so
ridiculous well thank you hold on hold
on let's be discerning here because
there's a lot of people could you see
yourself marrying a girl that doesn't
have a penis that's the hardest part
because just be honest here because we
have to call the hurt oh well yeah I
mean I don't I don't see myself marrying
so we have to say goodbye to I mean
right what a good only fans like if she
was eating me out with like a smurf like
a smurf only fans like fetish thing okay
well you can reach out to her first but
as far as right I got you but it's done
not ashamed then if they're gonna talk
you can't I restrict you from talking to
her we're trying to find love you know
you can't settle down without a penis we
all know that right yeah you're right
yeah okay so apologies to Jack C white
that we appreciate the submission we
appreciate the brevity of the submission
yeah I would be long ones I want to
watch long ones eventually Kyle Watson
says this is my audition to date Trisha
I want the Trish in all-caps he said so
Kyle Watson Oh a shirtless young man now
my initial Wow I think this guy's young
I'm here Peters bro you literally got a
McNugget he literally got a McNugget
meal mukbang I just did that yesterday I
did a McNugget meal
yeah but he just got like the straight
up like numbered one or whatever so
number seven I just got another stuff
honestly and he ate all the fries
already he's loki high but also sounds
kind of dumb he's like hey h3h thank you
with that this guy I'm not sure is
looking for love if I'm being all right
that's my first okay I see yeah well
let's watch why is he so Jack never
sounds high uh-huh how old is he
he looks like eight I mean he looks
young yeah I'm scared
my name is Reno I'm 23 and I know
tricked us that you only wanted older
he's so hot but I really think we can
make it work and here's why I have had
chlamydia three times it didn't render
me Owen wait he's that clean I can still
give Trisha codes I think I could become
a family man for Trish what do you think
about a man who so wax his chest
some people have employment no hairs
that keeps true oh wait hey wait he's
gay wait what women oh he's flaming gay
he said some people think he's flaming
but I think he's saying he's gay I hope
that keeps true he's saying I hope that
Colonel I think he actually I am getting
the gay vibe a little bit
hey I don't know if I can do another
game in love them don't know if I should
marry one she's just like the perfect
girl in that store you know see that's
false careers you're not the perfect
girl next door I am like so sweet I am
so but that's not what the girl next
door like wholesome and cue and like
wholesome come on this guy's gay all
right well well he said he was gay right
so I okay oh that's what he said and
we're not just assuming no he's gay I
could tell my gaydar is going off no
it's bouncing around well he said he's
gay but then I was like oh I totally see
it he's so cute he'll he left what is
happening honey on the nug you really
just bring me on What did he say I
should bring him on cuz what you're
after admit you have to admit I mean
Trisha do have a lying problem what what
am i honest ly this is a pretty low
effort to make there after watching it
he's not serious Kyle Watson is not
serious Dan remove him to the graveyard
next is from Jonathan Abe
Ibrahim I think that is probably an
Arabic name welcome in jump but Jonathan
is not an Arabic name unless he's
American Arab Ishmael is thank you
Jonathan Abraham says here's my entrance
video I believe I will win wow I really
get into it in the second half
we'll make sure to watch for that what's
up Dan my name's John six-foot 500 250
pounds yeah that's huge
it's like I think probably like uh okay
because you oh my god all that meat I've
been one isn't that how you do it that
scares me
yes I've nosey someone do that okay well
are you turned on when you saw that yeah
I don't like his lighting
I'm 100% Egyptian oh where is that I
think it's right next day it's south of
in the Middle East it's in hay right
next to Israel oh I never thought it was
a made-up place let me pause Patra wait
Egypt as in the fairy tale and it's like
Atlantis and and Cleopatra it's a Disney
story no no doesn't see that to me
is that real I thought those were like
the seventh one seven wonders or
something that's like doesn't exist or
it does exist
oh wait Stonehenge don't henge an
England but that doesn't exist right
this is a real thing this is Egypt Wow
actually real place yeah wow there's
like Pharaohs and stuff over there yep
really
Oh
yeah there's still a lot of Jews in
prison they're building they build these
pyramids here's the city of Egypt Weezy
these are the pyramids ancient pyramids
this is the desert that's like a you
know a National Historic Site and then
this is the city of Egypt Wow I mean not
the city of the Cairo ah there's
something like they don't know how they
build the pyramids right is that the
thing like it's a mystery they've
figured it out the slaves
yeah just like just human life really
this is a real photo Wow so there you go
yes to the Egyptian just straight I mean
yeah just from these I mean if his
people can do that no the Jews did
that's Jewish later but just for the
record know that you display it the
Jewish slaves built the pyramids I don't
want them to get any credit for that the
difference with the Jewish slaves the
Jewish slaves built the pair you want
them to have the credit one yeah don't
give the credit to the Egyptians okay
but it was their vision to be fair yes
Egyptians are cool though
I love the Egyptians yeah isn't that guy
who played Rami Malek is Egyptian and
I'm obsessed with him so I will take it
is he I thought you thought it was a
fiction fictitious place I didn't know
Egypt existed I thought some people were
real you know how there's like people
how's that possible
like Jewish people there's no Julian do
you know what I mean there is real okay
right so what I'm saying is I knew there
was Egyptian I didn't know they were
from Egypt okay not they're like chips
like Abu Dhabi or you know wherever
we're gypsies from Oh hyung green right
they are right I have cousins other
gypsies what was the other you said
something else that caught my attention
anyway interesting a little bit was fake
ID literally did cuz it's in the Bible
like Joe 17 Technicolor Dreamcoat he
went to pharaoh remember what the seven
years of corn atlantis by the way that's
Baker real because that's in the Bahamas
no that place is real that's that that's
east of Israel in the Mediterranean
Atlantis the city is an underwater no it
is a fictional looks like it's
underwater no it's a fictional but there
isn't a leonis in the Bahamas there is
yes
right I like him just because of the
pyramids oh yeah any other nice watch
you look like he's gonna high rise can
you tell it's like so dark a little dark
Nate
that's a Rolex amore when you stand up
commitment Oh how'd you spot that huge
watch guy so how much that watch con
Jack can you go to the is he single
are you married no girlfriend so sure so
wait you you need a better shot of the
watch SAP yeah I can tell you exactly
okay relax anyone right there
all right that's a later that's an early
model Submariner Yeah right there cause
um you could probably get those for 9 10
grand
oh okay it's not a presidential not mega
no no no flex no it's a nice watch ten
thousand for watches amazing I want to
be a stand-up comedian now so Oh he's
not very funny a very funny
wait do you know this guy wants to be a
stand-up comedian he's got the
opportunity to be seen by a bunch of
people he's sitting in the dark eating
wings like bro he's got a hostile I did
say sit in the I didn't I say sit in the
dark and speak plainly as possible what
we've we've had so much fun watching
this is like the saddest new playing of
all time what's he said oh he wants to
he says no pretty yeah oh oh he's rich I
think he wants your money I don't like
that attitude though I'm down to share
my money you should be down to share
yours I do real estate sales oh that's
the one most unfunny thing to me
Realtors like mega instant turnoff
yeah early in the video used to got real
do you have why does he have money he's
a realtor IG wagons like $170,000 car
they make a lot of money
I'm detailing this guy I'm sorry I
forbid you know I'm putting the
presidential stamp on this one but we
did learn that Egypt is a real country
that was excited Cairo is the Capitol's
I don't want people to think I'm a
dumbass flexing my knowledge no really
we almost went once and then a war broke
out it's awesome
well she was in the military she could
protect you yeah she could with gun
moving on we have a so we have two
finalists right only two yeah that's
perfect we know we have a lot more dude
Oh Mike I mean this is gonna be we're
gonna have to do another episode or we
just pick up the pace because we're
spending with 28 how can I not because
she wanted to say yes to that guy but
that goes a big no that's we have to put
in the time we're gonna have to do part
two you're gonna have to come back on
Tuesday I think it could be Friday oh we
got a bump in crasher he's married I
don't know him anyways I only like
machine you don't know I think she is
relatively famous I got black or
something Jack Black is mega famous yeah
I'll take him Jack what offer Chris oh
no anyways interested good I'm not
interested let's just keep going and
that's how you're gonna bump me for okay
here we go
Arden elite head says a very serious
application for the very serious
Bachelorette Trish love a godless love a
godless Oh
love a godless t-girl sorry I misread
that Satya girl godless though I mean I
think she's yeah I think she's just
being funny did they mean to say goddess
no it says love a godless t girl so she
saying she's godless yes but I think
that should
oh wait no wait do you know who this is
no didn't you say this person's like
somewhat uh no okay by the way this
video with four views was age restricted
what is going on in the city upside down
cross and that's I hate that why is this
age restricted is me oh by the uploader
okay okay made me nervous maybe she's
making a joke that she's just like dude
he rides it sorry I'm sorry she rides a
dragon dildo that's crazy don't that is
you must a dragon dildo no actually I
don't you don't you've never seen what
looks like a dragon call Rick and Hugh
well I can't show you we can't look on
your let's show her on your just like
it's called a show it on the screen if
you want we just won't cut through it so
yeah let me stage no I'll show you on
the screen dragon dildo like a big one
oh yeah bad dragon it's called right so
it's like this dragon oh my god it's
like that what I can't
oh no I'm like this whole thing she
makes me uncomfortable because she says
she rides a bad dragon I'm gonna mix it
right away because I think it's
blasphemous where are none the
upside-down cross like on it but let's
watch a little more because I like my
giant dragon dildo thank you that kills
and in the meantime I
listening h3 podcasters have paid it
he's pretty where she decided she was
going to accept video submissions for
her next relationship and I thought I
have to go Lord Baphomet is calling me
Oh another Antichrist I think before we
just burn in hell like I feel like
that's where we're going can we get rid
of this like illogical manipulation you
may be inclined to put me through well
it sounds like a big enough for Tricia's
we're not where she is you care about
something we love Jesus I love Jesus I
love Jesus but Jewish is fine they don't
believe in Jesus but I'll still do that
because I believe in God so that's fine
but no hating do you know lady yeah we
anti God no anti God I can convince
someone Jesus exists I can't convince
someone God is real you know are you
interested in saving her soul nope no
she's pretty and hardened a godless t
girl we are saying no to you thank you
for the submission though and jesus
loves you by the way Jesus Christ
Jews court video love you God like this
with you guys like with no windows it's
so like intimate I don't know what it is
I get really like endorphins rush to my
head are you turned on currently so this
one comes from Blair brine Gilson brine
Gelson and it just says bagel Blair's
the name so let's go ahead with bagel my
name is Blair
at your request I'm eating currently so
I'm at an Einstein bagel
I'm having my favorite
miel
basically
simple man bacon bacon cheddar bagel I
love a simple man with simple tastes
videos yeah I was like don't think the
right people so I mean the low effort
nature of this makes me think he's not
that dedicated entrepreneurs I live in
Denver Colorado
fish' I think you're [ __ ] hilarious I
think you would be these people who
invented them oh is the three guys
Baxter what why did you guys find this
one was except yeah what was the
consensus on bagel Blaire I never there
was no disagreement on this one so it
was up to these two
oh you guys put him through so how it
worked was that if there Dan or Ian and
Zach if they agreed they'd put him
through if there was a dispute Dan broke
the tie so Zach again what's going on
with bagel Blaire he's not a bad-looking
dude you guys just thought he was
handsome less like Trisha he said you
wanted like struggling or super rare so
I got that but we don't eat basic Zach
okay and you guys picked the two most
basic interns to pick the basic people
and that's why we're getting the
interval way singer why are we based our
T there's two that you loved I wasn't
trying to insult them I'm just saying I
don't get roasted in the comments cuz
well if they are right we already have
seen guys sitting in the dark that was
like an immediate yes with terrible
lighting and just to say with Matt she's
the she's he's the mythical range
Egyptian but I will say in their defense
Trisha we do have two big yeses who were
they I forgot who they were they're
worthy let's not go back all right
yeah but we only move forward I forgot
no there was two big yeses you're very
excited about but the lair the bagel boy
is a basic [ __ ] of
was that were calling oh yes tripolis
yes sorry
next we have Kai steel Smith he
sometimes like a porn star hi hopefully
there's enough energy in this for you
all and I didn't almost die for nothing
Oh adrenaline yes I love a guy who's
gonna die for me yeah I love it that he
didn't turn off his uh loveable engines
that's quite a spread he's got butter
sriracha what is he gonna do with the
bottle let his skinny wages when I
wrecked four and a half inches when a
rat when drunk he's poor
dude he's pouring butter over the
chicken I love it yeah pretty awesome
Lauren raised in California Bay Area
where's he filming this like bro look at
that wall oh my god it looks like a
prison
really loud fridge but nobody lives in a
room like that Wow
yeah don't even like that years
there's no installation small apartment
dude they're homeless he's homeless he
was homeless he that he's been away this
guy no no with the beard and they're my
goal and then we meet up you got your
father I love each other
nice to be your husband
I like him he sounds like he's been
through it if he's been homeless and
traveled around he's dedicated to we got
butter melted butter married he has a
ring on no I think this is probably
tough for the audio listeners you
getting turned on yeah can you tell me
on one to ten how turned on you're
getting okay ten what I'm ready to be mm
right now
now when you say ten what does that mean
what's happening like what a fabulous
face I dunno someone who looks like that
actually I can show you a picture like I
do doesn't want to look just like that
laughing my name's that I cried someone
is laughing about it I know that hold
the [ __ ] song hold on there that's a
female line yeah [ __ ] you go be homeless
and eat your chicken somewhere else h3
doesn't want you your camp oh that's
true you can bro that's not cool dude to
have your girlfriend film ass enjoy
you're not a joke I just make an aside
here we this is not a joke you went
through all this effort to have your
girlfriend I blamed the interns no this
was a good submission I mean they they
could they probably didn't pick up this
is dumb I'm over it
oh are we getting the other side of
Trish Deanna's like Trish I might not
come back and you know what maybe I
won't Wow
but we didn't we didn't think you're
turning on us wait we have two great
ones already
you're forgetting you want to see one of
the good ones no no because honestly
like I'm on your side I'm calling this
guy out I was like yo I heard a female
laugh he's out he's dead oh you're upset
you're sabotaging me this is interesting
I feel like we're getting the
personality it's multiple it's the brain
multiple loci steel Smith is a fraud you
were turned on your fans are the worst
I'm just gonna say h3 fans are the
[ __ ] worst
wait we had two great ones why are you
flip-flopping I was just too and it's
like we have like 20 more applicants
we're going slow she is sensitive and
you [ __ ] up the mood all right let's
just go fast oh man let's go on to the
next Derek black man oh I know him
this is some black guy on YouTube he's a
he's a friend he's a good dude I met up
with them his name is Derek black man
hey what's going on yes doing this is
your boy black Chad aka some black guy
aka Derek Blackman aka a dick down daddy
so we're doing a very special video here
it's gonna be a very special video doing
a mini mukbang how do you say that and
it is my official application to win
Trisha Paytas heart so what we got here
is one Papa John's regular pet cat you
know it doesn't usually work I think
it's pretty good I think Papa would give
this to a good score we got you know
this little thing right here like some
Kool Aid [ __ ] see I live in LA so you
gotta go to the local chicken joints cuz
they're better than anything else I
didn't show my face you like him
oh you you've turned the music off good
catch guys yeah he's awesome he's a good
dude going to be 32
wait what happened is it yet wait is
there music wait hold on is there
copyright music honk you played before
it was definitely caught but this sounds
like we're LC free but I can't take my
chances
Derek wait why do we hate that you don't
use what I mean oh it's good I hope on
guys get claim because he's I'd be a
good idea to put in music the whole
channel just a MIDI the whole video I
build a two hour podcast here I got I
have employees to pay I got to send your
ass 10 you fresh is one thing okay this
is another got bills to pay there - he
doesn't wanted to get D monetized yes oh
okay yeah I don't have only
fans okay you make like $10 it's not an
are you imagined just are sexy no dude
that would [ __ ] you know I would your no
I'm not I'm horrified I mean it's just
so awful because I'm sitting next to you
too and you guys are like my ideals hold
on I'm sorry Derek but our black met but
I know his name
let's show her him without a mask I'm
just okay well yeah wasn't the mask I'm
not I really don't know why he's wearing
a mask but look how he eats he lifts it
up and then I said I what it's some like
let me show you his mane - oh wow yeah
what was that I let me just show you his
um let me show you his mane child this
is how many subscribers he's called us
some black dude I think or guy you got
440,000 oh alright clout know he's yeah
okay we think yes to that rash and I'm
excited a good dude I had no idea what
he was like trying not to be associated
with me he's like I'm gonna do it but I
don't wanna be associated with Trisha
we're talking about here okay oh oh
really
born in 20,000 is good no okay I'm black
I won congratulations
I mean and he's actually a good guy cuz
we he's a good guy I got your house no
no I went out with no he's a nice guy
welcome there's way very we have a baby
we don't do anything I'm great with
babies okay Dre key mark and Drake
Martin oh my gosh I would I would not
trust you with him I would be so good
actually
Drake Martin says background music is
from YouTube's audio library Drake
Martin said in his application
background musics from YouTube's audio
library I said well I said if you submit
don't use music cuz well [ __ ] I'm
currently a second semester student at
the Berkeley College
Massachusetts not this little [ __ ] I'm
a musician and a bass player so as you
prefer
I am extremely broke with very little
prospects for the future I'm five seven
and I choose to not know how much I
weigh freshman 15 and my physician I am
on track of obtaining full ethan klein
the gentleman status i may not be the
most attractive person that you will see
on this screen today i think it is only
fair do you judge me by this photo of
myself completely undoctored i love
watching movies and TV my favorite movie
is ghostbusters my favorite TV show is
Arrested Development and a good taste
I felt I will lie and say it's offensive
if it means I can have sex with you
there's many perks of dating was you
desperately [ __ ] me I've been
watching h3 since I was a freshman in
high school so I know every single
questionable thing that Ethan has ever
done online and you can bring it up on
the podcast Oh maybe saying some batshit
insane stories and coming up some quick
video ideas now Trisha oh can I call you
Trisha I'm going to need a bit of that
lying about my gender identity for
YouTube use because I'm trying to become
a professional musician and I'm going to
a pretty expensive school there's one
more / - dating me and that's that you
can always be serenaded with songs like
this one did you clean your kitchen
floor he made a mistake in he's he's
catering to us because we have there's
this one song where Dre are not direct
are Kelly goes do you want to come to
America but you don't know that
reference and also like I need a
musician I have a band coming out I'm
forming a band and I need a bass player
but feeling he's a talented music like
yeah he looks like a nerd
well he got a sink penis eh he's a
sinker thank you very considerate is
time to hand Ethan that rose also I'm 18
[Music]
[Applause]
well I will say Drake that was an
awesome application the age is a killer
number one if you were like even 24 I
guess like damn 3 portray yeah well we
enjoyed we enjoyed your application next
up is stall bro he's a pretty popular
Instagram account here's my application
to date the love of my life Trisha show
what she and I have is truly beautiful I
love her personality and her other
personality and her other personality
and her other personality and her other
personality and her other personality
yes please don't get in the way of our
true love
oh so relevant because that was this is
stall bro what the hell is this this is
his Instagram what the [ __ ] voting under
the stall dude what a jerk we do with
the real savage culture
oh this must be Turkish okay then are
you registered to vote
you are Wow now I just want to watch
this video
[Laughter]
yo damn we gotta get this guy we gotta
get this guy in the show yeah I think he
follows us on all the we got we need we
need some exclusive content I'm stopping
the application I got to watch one more
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude this guy's literally in the
bathroom by himself
that's the gnarly [ __ ] why Oh Charles on
the song I'm just kidding gauged in the
left stop yeah can I ask for help
there's his girl on tinder and she and
she's kind of fine you can see
what do you mean she's fake she's hot
what do you mean reader out of ten where
you think all right I'm out all right
no I'm just out on the Instagram let's
watch the video application yeah stall
bro oh it's probably under the stall or
something right
you tell me one penis all bro [ __ ]
out like that beautiful and I think all
nine of your personalities are beautiful
too and I just wanted to let you know
that I'm interested in becoming your
bachelor and I hope you accept these
flowers I got for you
any questions you're probably wondering
why I'm on the toilet music sounds like
royalty free I'm I'm Stahl bro and I'm
known for doing bathroom pranks what the
emojis that turn you off because I'm
wondering so I just wonder if he was
gonna hand it to these flowers and I
hope that I can see that's it
what do you think I don't know he looks
like something yeah where we gotta show
him snow star bro oh that's a stall no
an Atreus who was a well really didn't
have much to say in his intro oh wow
eggs
and I'm here on the board my kitchen is
that royalty-free I'm gonna assume it is
yeah I think I'm racist against furries
I have to see like them
I'm arrived people say oh you don't like
this you don't like that I'm just gonna
flat out say I'm racist against first he
works in medicine can you imagine if you
knew your doctor the distance
could you take his advice is he release
somehow I like him I say yeah I like a
doctor or medicine do you not want to
see his face Angus beef hot dog
mayonnaise and eggs
oh he wait for the furry head that's
hard you so do those fries the enzyme
got you dude I'm gonna pass on this one
for you but we can put him through all
right
like I like a mr. Logan I like the I
like the aspects I think he's good okay
so we're keeping the otter so the next
one is Jared trees l'heure
my name is Jared and this is the link to
my entry video that's all he said I'm
very exciting I have to say oh they're
little captions yeah that's what I'm
reading oh wow he's [ __ ] with ya hello
Trisha yeah my name is Jared no jambe
Trish's future husband donut I don't
know a lot about Trisha besides what
I've seen at age three that's enough to
know that she's a beautiful woman oh
she's a hard-working go get her doing
whatever tapes it's like a woman that
really turns me on sincere about it it
sounds like it yeah like the mers real
one I think I'd make a nice trophy
husband oh yeah you're hot as [ __ ] he's
jacked yeah I don't think I don't think
this guy's had a donut in like [ __ ]
10 years I know you're gonna ban down by
the river
I'll come right over right now oh that's
against the rules were huh oh he lives
in a van 31 years old
me too US Navy veteran hot
I enjoy going to gym okay what else to
say your sex record for the day oh let's
do it oh yes to him I love him not quite
six one few inches shy okay
wait through some platform shoes nice
wig huh yeah doing it fast I don't know
if they're in the beards or not but I
love a beard you want me to shave it I
can shave it I'll put a link to another
video in the email options this seems
yeah seems genuine you think the first
one that's like not making too much of a
joke of it while showing his
personalities I'm just loving that
doughnut too
I know some giant balls that's actually
true ha okay so that's from that was
from Jarrod's yes so do you want to see
the additional link okay
I guess to him with no beard beard oh I
love a beard oh it's him on stage oh so
it wasn't a van for real I'm doubt I
don't care oh that's really him
so tan why did they do that other
muscles that's him
I guess it could be that guy's not a
joke
okay could look at it I know that's kind
of crazy I can I just want to meet that
guy he's everything okay yeah I think
he's like the leader so far so jared is
a big yes that's exciting you see I'm
not here to sabotage you okay right come
on I just really wanted to find like a
real boyfriend that's what we're here to
do we're not [ __ ] around
Joey I don't I don't think Ethan
actually gave us a time limit yes I did
I said to keep it about three minutes
max if it's too long I can shorten it
let me know so this from Joey
you guys haven't asked me about putting
the wrong email on the [ __ ] thing oh
then oh my god look at it screams she
does turn yeah I want with this terrible
lighting but you know sometimes we just
have to live with what we got
I don't really like the way of it
smashed it yeah natural light do you
hear oh he's like a pun can send that
natural light trying to stab me but then
you're like I've been from day one from
well from the moment we started this
it's always been serious and Joey too
much stick too much deck you're out
we're looking for a serious contestant
Sakaki seven one one seven one like
height I love that this is how we're
quarantined rotavirus boy your
application I had to cut down ten
minutes of my horrible eating into three
minutes that's my boy he follows
instructions Sakaki
[Music]
[Laughter]
I'm worried about the show yeah
[Music]
[Music]
personality of yours you think he's not
want you to like think they're funny and
have them on is like a gas you know they
want to be like a person on a dream they
need to find a good balance of being
entertaining and serious show your
personality they don't want to date me
and I feel like we said I'm not okay
let's move on we have a lot yeah we're
not wasting any time let's see yeah I
was like hoping maybe like Papa John
would apply or something like that's why
we're jamming on for you guys do we have
good ones why are you where you're
you've been like ten at a ten turned on
at the the last guy yeah I'm picking
like the best of the are you seriously
complaining about all these young men
throwing themselves at you come on
alright thank you guys for applying it's
very so this guy is apparently famous
Richie well we have - Richie a case
social repost do you know him
oh yeah you know him a youtuber he's a
famous well he applied what do you know
about him what did he really
yes he said
hi I did a little video for you here's
the unlisted lane he's a cheater but
that's fine he cheated on a famous
youtuber he has a 1 million subs zero oh
holy this will you expect my name is
Richie from social repos and this is my
dating application H 3 is this cause K
or something kind and sensual person she
receives a chubby chaser
okay on the internet that just compounds
itself over years and I would love to
show Tricia just complaining about the
quality of man which I believe I am
mentally and physically equipped to
handle I think what's going through your
mind right now
you seem so did you know he was
interested in his for liking like chubby
girls like he like he's like really into
it
have you guys been together no I never
met him but um he's made videos like
Trisha Paytas is hundred layers of con
video he like made fun of me the whole
time oh but that doesn't mean she
doesn't wanna know so when we tax I'm
like hey you can come on my podcast he's
kind of like seem like he's kind of like
a well-known youtuber he's been on the
cares about talents up I think my my
podcast
what's his talent he does like he's a
musician he does like he just like cups
he plays the cups or something like he
does like water he's like yeah so is
this a yes he seems genuinely interested
it's a lot of toxicity there and I feel
like if anyone's gonna take it on it
would be her potential partner to have a
dick one my name is Richard so my
nickname would be dick - Wow how'd he do
that
that's crazy older I am 80 years old 3
it is a match made in
if you just so happen to see this I will
treat you right I will treat you with
respect
and never let all those trolls get to
you because they're just jealous the
jealous of what you have they're jealous
of what you will become and they
probably look like feet so I just want
to see us thrive together I call black
shadow a void of a heart is in the right
place and I hope that you pick me and I
hope to hear so there you have it for
people who are watching he's in this
like really intricate costume he's got
black feathers and wings and claws it's
gnarly but it so so this is a yes are
you attracted them no and they've
already like established their like
relationship of some sort so it's like
it's kind of like not fair because I
already know him no do you wish he did
this off the show maybe though maybe
this was his way of proclaiming his love
for you so we're gonna move him through
would you want to have sex with him in
costume erratically I have like two
different types like a really old ass
like white man and like a really young
emo looking boy like I have those are
like me too okay so you like him cuz
here he is out of the costume
no he's super hot outside the costume
but he dated a couple youtubers and
cheated on them so I'm like nervous you
sure is that contested here yeah he's
hot well that's a yes then [ __ ] but it's
like we really know him so I feel like
that's like disqualifying cuz I we
already talked it's kinda like he got an
advantage yeah well if anything happens
you have to tell us
no yeah we haven't even met never met
her Virginie I believe but he comes out
to LA Loche always happens well
hopefully Alexa Antarctica all right so
he's throat congratulations social repo
is you seemed really excited about it oh
we're almost done were we're we're
working with no no really I don't that's
probably not my genre to be frank you
just like Saul bro
yes stall bros my [ __ ] valentino queen
no nose no message holy [ __ ] Doug oh
this guy's got a beautiful black mane
yes his body's crazy dude he's got a
nipple pierced I like that Hey
I'm welcome back to my channel so today
we move backward yes thirty thousand sub
all right he's not thank you and the
possible he's not gay I feel like it's
no for you I just get bright you skip
the four minutes forty seconds and he's
had one slice he's not like you even you
can't take you remembered I remember
that was like the best episode ever I
left as wet oh right what can I smell
well sometimes it stinks that's true and
sometimes mine does I'm not gonna lie
there you go it's what you want you're
like freshly washed it brings all the
odor out it's long has dress anyway so
Ritchie's I know or which ones don't
know no no that guys I know I just do
you okay Jake mole mullah Steen hey a
tree podcast my boy Chris what all right
I'm not gonna pass judgment yet my boy
Chris engaging and moping to win the
affection of the beautiful Trisha Paytas
but please see the link below please
reach out if you have any questions so I
don't know if this is one of these split
personality gags or is another friend
who's never the Internet
well I'm Chris from Orem Utah yeah yeah
I'm sorry I would definitely wait me and
what and what capacity it's two
subscribers and this has three like I'm
definitely interact with because the
amount of cheese in that that's where do
you get them a shoot impressive he's not
wasting the time I love the cuts Dan is
this music copyrighted is considerably
lower that's a good point
you got to get the best cost per nugget
yeah you like a cheap guy I know no I
don't like to guy but yeah he's
definitely know that was him that was
him
hold on hold on he's too messy actually
wait I'm curious if someone else was
live for hmm I think it's him thank you
someone else but it's a guy it sounded
closer to the camera hmm I'll taste you
messy I don't like messy I don't like
cheap it's not your bro yeah bad Achatz
cuz I feel like he goes all out I just
want to give the guy the credit mm-hmm
damn know that he looks like he just it
looks like you have chlamydia and he
just changed you out you like no you
also think my [ __ ] smells you're like I
smell
no I didn't you did say that you said is
this let's move past that it's not like
a [ __ ] orgasm on the chair Jesus
really going for it probably not your
type I want to give him the credit oh I
like dedication
even resonates tallboy Sifl I like that
not turned off not the slightest you're
back to 1 or 0 I just realize I'm gonna
be single forever like after watching
mittens I'm like I'm done this is it oh
my god I don't want to like he's
committed I like one of you and I'm not
kidding cute oh my god he's covered his
whole head and not good he's kidding I
guess that explains to the tarp doesn't
it when you wanted to go down on you
with why not that seems like something
you'd be into when you want to make out
with them why does that disgust you you
literally put an alfredo sauce in your
vagina you know it's funny here it looks
like a a memorial it looks like he died
thank you thank you thank you for the
video
I don't know if this Jake or Chris let's
see if we can get it back we can moisten
it back up with Ben Ferrell guys we're
almost doing in here with three more
three more I know how long with me going
probably close to two hours that's
perfect I mean I always get so pissed
I'm like why don't they do long episode
with me I can talk I can do a five-hour
episode and Ferrell says hello HT
podcast gang my name's Ben I make a
mukbang video for Trisha so here it is
and if there's a problem with the link
please don't hesitate to contact me well
it's too late if there's a problem
she wants a fly to youtube link and this
is how I know Ian and Zach picked them
because they all look like Ian and Zach
them combined like they look like
interns at age three pies what does that
mean
look like you guys what what does that
mean yeah don't you think have a very
similar vibe to your interns like all
these guys the guy from Berkeley this
guy like they all have very internalized
for age three what do you mean by
interning they just look like them
that's what I'm saying like the people
out there they don't look like [ __ ] boys
no but um packet what does it say about
them I just think okay like you're an
intern at a podcast that's cool like
that's you know they're not interns to
all these guys okay employees that's
what I met employees I might have that's
cool like it someone help me podcast oh
my god I know if they're in a boy
[ __ ] like okay you know what I mean
but isn't that good there's not
something you want actually what if the
guys got its to middle ground it's like
not bad not good it's too good so you
want something someone more pathetic or
more gray why seeing a green screen in a
restaurant in a Chinese buffet bang very
cool paintings to show your head a
buffet you could load that plate up I
guess it should be I don't know oh it's
real
oh it is really you're right business so
it's not really my fault that I'm at
unemployed he's unemployed living with
my parents
he lives with his parents that's good
here's the thing I'm pretty sure that I
am NOT Trisha since I've been taking a
head-on in my type but then again oh no
that's how you get a girl
because I'm not her type but she's not
my let me skip to the hand I want to
give me I know he hates not though hey I
probably should have stopped like two
plates ago
but in for a penny in for cake so even
if this doesn't end up working out for
me yeah we got yeah it's not oh and he
wrote he wrote I was actually planning
off the contacting you guys answering
related this is someone else I just made
sound related today well yeah I just
want to eight connects showcases that
he's not serious does he wanted to show
me this video year h3 cube build you
wants to be an employer well you might
be right I'm related to Trisha he made a
cool am I not beautiful wait that's your
head what's the beanie that's not picked
out there of everyone in red beanie
beanies at Disneyland no we were just we
just all worry it's like your thing I
maybe it used to be sure
all right cool dude be a part of that
group photo I do mean thank you for
honoring me with the statue we are in a
hurry though Ben so I don't have all the
time to watch black Bugatti oh what is
going on YouTube black here coming to
you live but not live from Atlanta
Georgia it's kind of 77,000 right now he
lives in his car video well as the title
says I want to ask is that a nice voice
like a like a like I know you're saying
what's the garbage character from the
Sesame Street Oscar the ground I know
she's pretty famous on YouTube she has
millions of subscribers she's famous
she's probably pretty loaded she's cute
whatever she's a almost like a c-list
celebrity and Alma well
there i accidentally drink my own piss
twice it within 15 minutes tell me more
yeah you know that terribly attractive
I got a bad disposition I at little
children when they run in front of me at
the supermarket
I dig in dumpsters for food that people
don't want anymore
is that real I think thanks I have a
small dick others follow the law I have
road rage issues
low-key so hot I am a suspect in several
crimes I want to come from the heart for
me I want to come from the heart for a
minute now if I were able to show if
he's gonna actually come to harm I'm
really impressed
after downing maybe a pint of taka I
think that would be able to build up the
liquid courage to ask her out on a date
I will say this about Trisha Paytas I
don't pull any punches she's an absolute
[ __ ] show I think she would like me I
think strong I'm not manly you know all
these things you know what I'm saying I
got a lot of faults psychological but I
will say this oh he's got great hurt
though I love his love like keep looking
at them Wow apparently he knows it tells
ya nice eyes and lips did what me and I
think I do have
a chance I have a small chance of
possibly getting this video seen by her
and her actually giving me a chance
giving me a go we don't even got to make
a video about it I would just like to
meet her in person and I will pay for I
will pay for it for what no I won't pay
for it you'll pay for this because what
I would do is I would start another
GoFundMe oh my god what it said is
number in the description but okay well
he says Trisha call me here's his phone
number I'll call him right now
what's his name wait wait 972 isn't that
okay yeah that's the country code yet
972 no no no no he's he's in America
area code 972 it's Texas 972 no I mean
he wrote it I'll write nine seven two
seven six five eight nine seven two I
mean this is a public video it's got
already six thousand five let's just get
him on the phone first yeah
okay no you can't see it from there yeah
what's his name Blackman daddy yeah yeah
speaker it put it up to the mic oh no
what a [ __ ] douche he did this he's
one of those public number both what is
that that why don't ya I said don't know
and I am bothers me a little bit the
other day and I texted him it's justice
it's some kind of AD like it's so weird
I texted Jared Leto and he's like hey
this is really Jared Leto likes ain't my
number but it was off from his Instagram
but obviously it's not him so I'm so
confused why they do that some kind of
marketing scheme where they get your
number and then text you [ __ ] you should
leave a message like hey guess what
idiot this is actually attrition you
[ __ ] up yeah let's do it let's call
and be like yo black Bugatti [ __ ] your
[ __ ] number cuz I hate when people
do now he has my phone number no just
tell me we get it everyone gets it oh
good hey I was really interested in
dating you and then you gave this number
and I called it and I'm really like
upset now because I sat through here
three hours we found your video I was so
in love with you I thought you were
gorgeous and we were so excited to fly
you to LA and also maybe take a cruise
to Antarctica and you [ __ ] it up so
you dumb [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] don't
spam me with this phone number don't
call me back and don't talk to my
friends h3h3 anymore bye [ __ ] number
so but do you want to keep them or cut
them for the [ __ ] number could you
read all that so Samuel so this is the
last one all right Samuel Sultana loved
the show here's the link to my
submission thanks and for every years
Sam productions and h3 podcast this is
Samuel Sultana making my entry for you
Trisha Paytas my love I'm in a row with
you already and everybody there's not a
chance
what is it that hates me I'm an artist
in all right this is it real I make real
films what I'm trying to say is that I'm
a veteran x4 I'm also unemployed
meaning how's that roommate best of both
words like he murders people and that's
the way a wallpaper he's in Eastern
Europe but big I mean basically
everything in between the ranges that
you said yes basically Tricia it's very
simple when you're gonna be talking
about me to all your friends this is
obviously not even in the country right
I mean oh wow this guy's got a hole he's
eating a salad you're gonna make a salad
growing it through with that [ __ ] oh
maybe you're right
clearly not much to say there's still
[ __ ] four minutes so we have in in
the end we have six finalists Wow Thanks
yeah that's pretty good
we've got the four Reds a bit of my Nico
anyway we don't need a bruise can I just
say yeah I thought I don't know if I can
say this you can cut it if I'm not
supposed to say this but I was like
low-key hoping because originally I was
pitched the idea to come on as a
contestant and heelas brothers gonna be
the bachelor and then I thought maybe he
would apply to be on my battery he was
supposed to I don't know what happened
we could take a last minute submission I
don't say do you want go I think he's
he's honestly super busy he's like a
[ __ ] mega hard work he's like a he
should make time though right you should
make time he looks so hot I was like
Loki impresses like holy [ __ ] what woman
he's like he's strikingly high okay
we'll make sure he gets in we'll take a
last minute mm-hmm but he lives here in
LA super successful long hair I love it
I looked him up you get a chance to know
Jesus I'm like
he's Jewish he's okay
we'll make sure we get ah if not we can
just also hook up we don't have to date
no no he's got to come to this why
because then it's a shame he's gonna
tell us you can't you guys can't get
past us he's gonna tell you I don't
think so
so we have six strong contestants West's
possibly seventh with us brother we're
gonna get a last minute so that's
exciting soap and probably two weeks
we're going to contact the winners we're
gonna set everyone up and then we're
gonna bring you back in and we're gonna
give each of them a three minutes to
impress you on skype you guys are gonna
have a conversation at speed dating
three minutes or five so I come dressed
up like a nice grass and my hair down
like updo do whatever you like yeah I'm
gonna come fancy for them so do you want
three or five minutes to have a
one-on-one blind date because I just
feel like a five minutes could get
awkward yeah maybe you should have an
abort button you can be like if it gets
too awkward you can abort well you
thought like a bar okay I want an
abortion with them or not I was like oh
I don't know that's like I'm ready to
say I mean yeah we didn't quite get
there yet okay let's wait for the cruise
to decide on that brother think I'm hot
though he like was out I don't talk to
him but he knew no he wanted yeah he
wanted to he wanted to apply though he
did tell us he was going to look in a
serious way yes Wow why haven't you let
them might even through all this why I'm
just like oh like you that's where they
want to see you I'd be like yes
he doesn't want Miriam necessarily you
know
okay Jewish well I don't know all right
come on what come on oh so that he said
that he was going to apply it we're
gonna that's all I know he definitely
doesn't look for it
- holy [ __ ] [ __ ] well make sure we
got his application so you might oh are
you really why would you some we're
talking about like sardines in here all
right
well we well yeah this excited we'll get
we'll get moses in here - okay and he
looks like Jesus the hell of it
sorry what was that what did she say his
name is Moses he might spread your Red
Sea
yeah gonna eat you out when you're on
your period he's into that let you out
on your period oh yeah for sure
are you kidding me [ __ ] is natural
natural eating someone baby was born
with blood on it well I can say drink it
you just you look it up you don't
actually like a sumo kay so next up
we're gonna do a new segment with Dan if
you'd like to stay enjoying oh you
didn't protect you didn't prepare the
news oh no no we're not no we're not a
tower was a charity stream was a
nightmare you can be you can be when do
we do it next yeah yeah we should now
because we're all quarantine for Corona
no we're not stay here daddy bring him
worthy he's at the house you like a
babysitter
his mom no he's taking care of himself
[Laughter]
all right oh my god really excited yeah
I got really
I remember this guy - you're super
pumped about I'm well that's a different
kind of weird to me but okay I'm done
look how hot he is not my type
I'm actually excited - about the guy
that ate the wings with the tie that dip
the time ran right what's with the whole
like main thing well you're the one done
is to date anything so exactly no I'm
more of that like my background is like
see my phone like that's my type okay
the dude from My Chemical Romance let me
knock is he doing promotion now for his
tour I feel he's didn't like not come on
my podcast but so okay well then that's
it so we have six finals we've done it
we've time we've talked about it all is
there anything else to say here on this
uh on this glorious Friday afternoon oh
no should we do some dead air do you
know what that air is just
nobody talks so here we go dead air
smiling okay dead air is great because
an audio listeners be like did they stop
talking I'm excited at hope my god I'm
so not till two weeks cause so much time
in between damn I found him through I
went to your followers you are do follow
on no I thought that was weird but maybe
I can know really attractive person and
you make yourself as honest as possible
like you like video so you like you put
your expectations low for people do you
know what I think I've been I think
about it I think that no this this is
kind of like a really weird analysis of
myself but I feel like I intent
are subconsciously make myself as
unattractive as possible because of my
dad because he's such a creep and weirdo
and I don't want female attention
because I don't because I want to be
true to you and faithful to you and I
don't want other women to be attracted
to me Oh because your dad was like a I
heard that yeah yeah where's he is you
applying to the show thank you stop is
he single or married
he's married my mom dads are always so
hot I'm not gonna call me just one
animal sobs I'll say could you render
how [ __ ] your dad that'd be crazy my
dad probably would really like that
because he probably would that's a I
mean I probably shouldn't even talk
about that
wait where is he is he Nellie yeah here
he is yes what what yeah yeah he doesn't
look anything like me
holy [ __ ] that's my dad that's my mom
that's Wendy well Wow we like low-key
your parents are attracted that's so
weird yeah they are both attractive is
it a big age gap what is this oh they
didn't realize they're on camera my dad
was patting my mom's bass we actually
where's your mom they were on the show
oh yeah here it is live stream Phil wow
this has 300,000 views Wow what's with
that lower third it's so ghetto were you
not here at the time dude this was like
my second episode I was just coming in
for us what's the show because my dad is
a what did you expect this is what we're
on Twitch and we didn't actually by the
way I'm also
surprise they're my parents I feel like
I'm adopted I think I'm so confused you
look nothing like either of them how old
is your mom how old is your mom um this
was this was two years ago so she's I
think she's like 16 I honestly don't
know her exact age she's like no she's
she's like 60 not like in her sixties
she's like 60 I'm so maybe she's 65
actually my dad is 70 well your dad a
hippie
no I don't look like one like I guess he
was guys I'm so confused that is so
bizarre you look nothing like them I
agree I've always thought I was adopted
and I'm and I'm nothing like them right
you yeah nothing nothing like my dad
right the only thing that makes me know
that he's not adopted is that it has a
brother and a sister and they all look
alike the siblings oh I didn't know I
think you're the only child you strike
me isn't only T strikes me I don't know
what do you think about this you think
I'm on wait that's you these ugly faces
on purpose I guess that makes sense if
you don't want female attention cos you
don't want to be tempted I don't want to
be tempting yeah you're doing a good job
of turning people off with that picture
that's why you don't think I look in the
Hat like all those people have ever seen
a view i mchao you're disgusting but
then I see you in person there's like oh
he's like super hot so I feel like thank
you for hot yeah I can see how pretty I
could see how you were trying to make
yourself on attractive I guess if you
don't want to be tempted by people
that's right that is that I think the
deep psychological issues um you're like
dark - you're like darkest [ __ ] damn
it's not that dark
how dark I just don't wanna be like my
dad make yourself so ugly so no it's -
Beatrice it's not like a it's not it's
just a thought that's that I've thrown
around because it's not it's not
something I'm consciously doing can I
ask you it like a personal question only
cuz I relate to it okay so like your
parents are both very attractive and fit
and so are my parents they've always
been in good shape and sup how do you
feel because like I feel like for me I'm
I'm always like the kind of the fat one
of the family and they're like what
happened to you like your sisters hot
your brother's hot your parents are hot
and it's like so how do you feel about
that
like having superhot parents um I think
that they it doesn't bother me I think
they're annoying and I think that they
don't add they're not I think they're
both really vain - do you think they
love you less because no I feel like my
parents
maybe not let me last what they don't
like I'll trash like don't think no I
think they just worry about me being
unhealthy that you're not you're not
that and you know I think you're super
hot I'm overweight I'm overweight well I
mean yeah thing but I feel like
everybody's overweight like 85% of the
world's over way but I feel like that
guy's so hot Gary Cola
although he had an incident recently but
anyways um I just wondered because I
feel like really no I don't feel I don't
feel like they were well which one all
of it all of it right yes I don't feel
that way I think it might be different
for women I feel like if I had a mom
that was like hotter than me it'd
probably be weird so my actually my
sister my mom have a weird tension
you're heavy chubby kinda well she's
done weight swings I'm not gonna say it
one way or the other but what you called
me fat you out oh yeah I want to call my
sister fat like a stranger I'm joking I
know but my sister my mom do you have a
weird relationship I think where they
had like yeah I think but both my dad I
just I never liked him oh that's so
brutal I guess I never connected with
him though there was not math there
wasn't really a competitive nature
between us what do you think because
you're not super like masculine and
stuff maybe he was like oh I don't know
it's not super masculine he likes sports
and [ __ ] but I've never been yeah
they're hot they're [ __ ] hot that's
crazy and then they wanted to drop bull
with them oh yeah he was exquisite your
touch I don't picture you just like
squeezing kilos trash out there you own
a mob lick cuz I'm saying I like it when
people do it in public that means that
can't contain themselves what do we do
here we go everything like someone just
catch it I'll catch it one day on my
tick-tock die
do we have anything else to discuss
No
I love no I love by the way I love my
dad because I say these things and he
listens and he and then yeah you get sad
I do love my dad it's just hard I want
to talk about him in a way that I'm
being too harsh I love my dad obviously
his shortcomings as every human being
does and he has to find Who I am not
because I want to be anything like a
movie I want to be the absolute opposite
of them no I'm just kidding I came out
and I'm just kidding again how do we cut
this no no sex for me and your dad
together you can follow him on Instagram
I'm doing it right [ __ ] now holy [ __ ]
my dad would actually responder damn
right I know that's the thing I know he
would answer your dams wait what a name
this is so sick
we have to stop I can find out I don't
think he's on there I wouldn't add my
dad are you crazy do you think I would
tag my dad you know what's funny my dad
on Twitter he follow those like um like
porn encounter and it shows up on my
keys sometimes he likes it and it shows
up on my feet oh yeah was on the
subreddit people saw my dad's Porsche
clean up on their feed do you not follow
your dad I think I may have unfolding
because I don't want people to find his
account do what you're doing right now
where is he oh my god this is so
annoying cause there's so many of them
okay we're gonna wrap this up you don't
follow my dad is there anything else Dan
let's stay safe use the Clorox wipes
stay six feet away from people
apparently make it ten just to be safe
if you're around Trisha make it 20
really all right well Bachelorette C of
episode three is coming at you
and we're gonna wrap this one up right
down yeah and next week we have Bert
Kreischer coming yeah Bert Christ don't
shoot like that Wednesday Wednesday
right he's coming in Wednesday so that
episode
won't go up until Thursday unless we're
able to rush it out maybe we'll try and
get it up once a just to keep consistent
is a popular podcast guest bird is a
very funny and he's a huge comedian so
yeah he's awesome his last episode with
us some of the hardest I've ever laughed
on the show he's super boss why don't
you post mome back that's your relevancy
right there well people know us friends
with him I didn't know I look googled it
you guys like blogs together yeah we
used to be close friends but I haven't
talked to him in a while he got you
famous for you I mean that that's yeah
probably I mean I don't know how else to
put it
he doesn't really he I mean he's got a
lot going on
I don't play I'm not I'm not I don't
blame him he's got a lot going doesn't
moved away from LA doesn't live here
where does he live him I got so many
people to be I'm Gary Moses
post well okay let's end the show love
you guys have a fantastic weekend stay
safe stay vigilant we will defeat the
virus together not the Boomer Doomer
what do they call it the boomer do rumor
remover the Boomer remover that's very
insensitive good the Boomer Goomer
the Boomer doom that's crazy but it's
actress it's actually true like they're
I think like every old person is just
mr. die I mean that's life no but like
sudden oh yeah not like eventual there
I've no one to [ __ ] you up later
alright let's end this again get this
turning into a nightmare alright and
this quarter for me Dan thank you guys
thanks everybody
[Music]